hey guys today we're gonna talk about a
very fascinating interesting topic
zinc okay now because zinc is so vital
for your body and it's just a
fascinating mineral I created three
parts first thing you need to know is
two billion people on this planet are
deficient in zinc that's crazy that's a
lot of people that are deficient I would
imagine it's even more than that as far
as being at having a subclinical
deficiency and as we go through this
you'll see what I'm talking about
one thing about zinc is the body does
not store it so you have to constantly
actually take it in and it's a trace
mineral we need it in smaller amounts
compared to things like potassium and
it's essential so what does it mainly do
it acts as a cofactor okay for over a
thousand enzymes so you have all these
chemical reactions going on at the
cellular level with DNA turning into RNA
which is the kind of the blueprints to
turning into the copy of those
blueprints and the transcription and the
interpretation and all that and the
building of proteins all needs zinc so
the enzymes are those things in the body
that do all the work and they need
certain minerals to accomplish their job
ten percent of all human protein is
bound to zinc it's a vital vital
nutrient it's the most common deficiency
in crops so I want to read something
here scarcity in the soil deficiency of
micronutrients are essential for plant
growth can lead to a lower crop yield
during the past decade soil
micronutrient deficiencies have been
ascertained primarily for zinc to a
lesser extent boron and molybdenum sol
deficiencies of zinc are widespread in
Asia scarcity and feed and food and
human nutrition zinc deficiency is the
most well known micronutrient deficiency
zinc deficiency can cause disorders in
humans such as growth and
children we talked about an estimated of
a third of population is at risk for
zinc deficiency
is the fifth most important risk factor
for disease in developing countries
scarcity of mineral deficiencies of
micronutrients and agricultural soils
can be replenished with mined minerals
and then they talk about a lot of these
minerals are used exclusively for
industrial applications not crops
livestock or for humans the mineral
reserves in relation to the use seem to
be most restricted for zinc at the
current level of production of mining we
have a reserve for approximately another
21 years so at that point I don't know
what's going to happen priorities should
be given to zinc because zinc
deficiencies are already occurring in
food chains in a large part of the
world's now on top of that glyphosate as
in GMO foods Roundup Ready acts as a
major key later to bind in block zinc
and other minerals now I couldn't find
the data and currently but in 2007 they
were putting 80 thousand metric tons of
glyphosate into the environment don't
worry it gets worse alright so now let's
get into the symptoms of what happens
when your zinc deficient growth
retardation okay so if you're pregnant
if you're breastfeeding make sure are
you taking the trace minerals including
the zinc to maximize growth of that
child loss of taste and/or smell a
lowered immune system which we'll get
into in the next video prostate
testosterone issues skin problems major
depression zinc is intimately involved
in insulin production another side
effect of zinc deficiency is diarrhea
eye problems delayed healing ulcers of
the mouth of the digestive system zinc
is a really good remedy for ulcers of
the stomach as well macular degeneration
related to age inflammation in general
zinc is a natural anti-inflammatory it's
a very powerful antioxidant as well and
I'm going to talk about some of these
other things in more detail in the next
couple videos the
foods that are highest in zinc our
oysters beef crab and pumpkin seeds by
the way now there's other things that
will decrease your absorption of zinc if
you had a gastric bypass surgery if you
had any type of digestive damage like
IBS Crohn's diverticulitis
you've had a lot of antibiotics that can
create a problem
liver disease cirrhosis things like that
and also if you have lower stomach acids
so many people don't have enough stomach
acid because you need this acid to
absorb these minerals how do you know if
you're deficient well if you have
heartburn chances are you're deficient
in the acid that you need to absorb the
minerals and especially if you're taking
an anti acid all right phytates
or phytic acid that would be in grains
whole grains like it's in the brand or
the fiber of whole grains and legumes
and this compound actually blocks the
absorption of zinc so it's actually kind
of like a key later it binds it very
similar to glyphosate diabetes okay
having high blood sugar because a high
carb diet will deplete zinc as well so
we're living in this environment and
it's making it very hard to get zinc
with the GMO foods the high carb diets
with the soil becoming depleted and with
all the pre-existing digestive problems
that we normally have not to mention low
stomach acids because I really wanted to
bring up your awareness of these
connections between these problems in a
simple trace mineral all right let's go
to part two
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it